poêle électrique qui a fait une belle
carrière voilà conclusion je suis à me
remplir un chèque de ma vie moi je suis
vraiment dans son garage c'est un peu
comme remonter le temps une carrière de
ferronnier et des voyages à travers la
France pendant 25 ans son travail le
plus emblématique certainement se grille
bien connu des visiteurs de Disneyland
Paris sa carrière son amour du travail
manuel et son enfance avec l'aide d'une
biographe il termine le récit de sa vie
3e de 13 enfants il grandit pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale des temps
difficiles qui forgeron son caractère
faisait 30 km sans chaussures chercher
du pain en sortie quai j'avais 253
lettres tendu dans la campagne que je te
vois des hier à tout de suite
que je j'avais des clients un livre pour
ses 88 ans destiné à ses enfants et ses
5 petits-enfants c'est Odette son épouse
qui l'a encouragé à raconter son
histoire et connaîtront jamais et
difficultés que
Émile et moi-même avons eu pas
possible
une fois n'est pas coutume Émile laisse
la main ici pour l'écriture sa plume
c'est Frédéric avec lave ils ont
commencé leur entretien en mars dernier
comme ça on a une relation les yeux dans
les yeux en fait je suis pas là en train
de gratter la sur la table donc après je
vais écoute tout je retranscris tout
c'est ma façon de faire j'en ai testé
plusieurs mais c'est celle-ci que j'ai
retenu et cette année sous le sapin le
récit d'une vie construite à la force
des mains